let me introduce our two distinguished
speakers
so first is Martin Fisher who is the
Kumagai professor at Stanford School of
Engineering and a senior fellow at the
Precourt Institute for energy where
fishers research goals are to improve
the productivity of project teams
involved in designing building and
operating facilities and to enhance the
sustainability of the built environment
I'm sure many of you are already
familiar with his work it develops the
theoretical foundations and applications
for virtual design and construction and
he's also quite the educator on vbc and
I think we'll talk a little bit more
about that at the end but he's developed
several workshops and courses that that
instruct people on VDC joining him is
Danielle didn't show the co-founder and
CEO of via Technic a virtual design and
construction consulting and
implementation firm transforming the
real estate and construction industry by
spearheading the advancement Building
Information modeling BBC virtual reality
augmented reality and artificial
intelligence she was awarded building
design and construction 40 under 40 in
2018 and Ian our top young professional
in the knack 20
it's honored that both of them here
today to talk about VDC a little bit
more about virtual design and
construction how it can help you take
your projects to the next level in terms
of the efficient so with that I'm going
to hand the presentation over to both of
them Martin yeah good morning thank you
packs good morning afternoon evening
from my home here in Menlo Park I'm
Martin Fisher from Stanford and together
with my co-presenter Danielle deboned
Shaw I'm very happy to welcome you to
this introduction to VDC virtual design
and construction we'll explain why
professionals projects and companies use
VDC as a project management approach or
framework and what VDC is we will
showcase how projects have benefited
from the application of VDC Before we
jump into these topics we'll say a few
more words about ourselves so that you
know where we are coming from
yep so I grew up in Switzerland as you
may detect on a accent and you see here
the house I grew up in and in the left
picture my father or me to cover for my
father is the one in the in the right I
grew up on one construction and as we
were building our house like every other
client we had more vicious than we had
budget and so be children had to help my
sister and I had to help build the house
on the weekends so I was once on
Saturday working on the top floor my
father gave me a task I finished it and
said hey come take a look
and he said okay yeah you didn't okay
job you know you would have done a
better job if you had used the
particular tool why why did you not use
the tool the tool was in the basement
and you know I would have had to go get
it and come back up two floors that was
a little much for an 11-year old boy to
do so I just muddled through so to that
this is what I heard from my father he
said you are an idiot if you're not
using the best tool possible and this
has really stuck with me so I've only to
share this little story so now you know
where I'm coming from I grew up in that
sense but also where I'm coming from in
my mind because I'm always looking at
the work we do as engineers managers
designers architects and so on it's AC
professionals and think about are we
really using the best tools because when
we have our tools we can achieve better
things and unlike that Daniel say a few
more words about yourself thanks Martin
I really love that story
so a little bit about myself I grew up
in the construction industry my parents
started a infrastructure construction
company when I was about three years old
so it's an industry that's very near and
dear to my heart but I couldn't help but
feeling that as time went on so much
technology was hitting the world and our
lives were changing but a lot of
construction was same stagnant so about
eight years ago I founded a company
called the attachment which focuses
bringing that sort of technology you
know BBC and related tools to the
industry we work with companies in three
different ways one is emitting Pfizer II
capacity so really understanding what's
your corporate strategy and how does a
digital strategy align to that also
through development and implementation
so actually implementing VDC and then
through education so I'm very excited to
be here today thank you very much for
joining us and bring this sense of
reality okay so why do professionals
around the world use VDC it's really
they want to create high-performing
buildings were often bring new
technologies into their practice in a
systematic way and consistently and
achieve their corporate aspirations and
also avoid rework
so very quickly illustrators we see
remarkable projects around the world for
many different reasons depends on the
aspirations of a client for example the
Tesla Giga factory was built designed
and built incredibly fast and actually
offers a lot of flexibility in its
layout the the bullet centre in in
Seattle amazing environmental
performance there's being born of
positive energy positive building on the
lower right became was very a fast
affordable but also became because of
that and sustainable because of that
became the highest money-making real
estate deal in Arizona or inland
Switzerland the longest tunnel or maybe
tunnel ever built
so there's many criteria that we can
apply to define what is high-performance
and we see some very high-performing
buildings but we also know that too
often we have buildings that don't
perform quite as highly as they should
what we found with BBC you have a better
chance of creating a high-performing
building we bombard it every day with
new technologies around mobile cloud
dimensional control machine learning AI
Internet of Things 3d printing
which reality and so on many
technologies everyone by themselves
already a big deal but and in fact
they're all happening right now and what
we've seen is that you can bring these
technologies into your practice in a
much more focused so keechak way when
you berkeley the framework like PDC i
was browsing across a number of websites
of companies around the world and
basically these are the kinds of
statements you read and look for sort of
the first opening statement that
presents the company you know Brooke
read all the policy involve a chief
common goals we think designing
construction improved performance
focused on the success of clients and so
on I'm sure you've seen these
aspirations as well which are of course
fantastic but again how are we going to
make sure that every project achieves
these kinds of aspirations and and again
we have found that PDC is really a way
to do so and finally we see still too
many problems on site that should not
happen that require rework that various
resources like this example here again
from my home country obviously something
has to give you cannot put the duck
through that hole while the electric
authorities in front of it so these are
really the the reasons we've seen by
companies are moving towards VDC so let
me introduce VDC in a nutshell so if an
idea what it is in my mind is really how
you would logically manage projects in
20 funny but of course it's not always
that easy to do the thing that's logic
so but let me explain what we do see is
so of course to have a great project you
will bring the right people together
together at the same time so that you
have the knowledge available you need
for the input and the project for the
decision making so that those decisions
stick you have you move forward in a in
a concerted way and don't have to come
back because some ideas show up too late
so you putting the right people together
but of course in 2020 there's only so
much we can do without digital tools so
you give them the best tools possible
because you have a great team so usually
cook the team with great tools and in
particular
the tools that really important is one
that focuses on what the client our
clients are buying and if you are
working from own or that also means the
clients that the users of the building
for example so well they are buying a
building erode at Apple physical
structure from us so we need a tool that
puts what we design build operate in to
the computer in digital form so we can
share the information about it we can
see it we all see the same thing
so a tool like bim is particularly
important given the value that we create
for our clients okay but the best people
the best tools together don't achieve
much if you don't put them in a good
workflow so if you don't align for
example the liberty of design with the
architects and construction then the
project will not be successful so here
you see from a hospital project in San
Francisco the left and the left I'm and
shows how far the architects slaughter
gonna take the design the right triangle
a time it shows how Verde builders
thought they would pick it up obviously
there was a gap they were both working
we'd been but there was a gap and so
they figured about early enough and
co-created the workflow that allowed
them to be successful they not point
fingers at each other and so back the
best people the best tools the best
workflows will not achieve anything
meaningful if you're not focused on the
right things so we have to establish and
track client and project objectives so
this this is really see right bringing
people together we call it integrated
concurrent engineering very very key
that we bring the people together
concurrently and solve problems together
we give them tools like Building
Information models we put them in the
right management approach project
production management we call it I focus
on the production of the project and
together with these methods of managing
people technology in process we achieve
what we found greater projects and
client objectives
they are defined in quantifiable
measurable ways so this is VDC as a
whole and VDC in a nutshell will
illustrate the application as you go
forward we show this typically as a
framework like this where you have the
client objectives that give rise to the
project objectives then that allow you
to figure out who are the people we need
to have on the project what tools do
they need and what's the right process
so that they can achieve those
objectives so you can think of EDC in
this way who should work together on
what tools should they use sorry here
how should they work and what should the
achieve or you can approach it in this
way you could say - the project exists
but what does the client really need
this building structure for what does
the project in there for me to achieve
our objectives and how a supportive team
going to achieve these results this are
the BBC capabilities that need to be
brought into an organization you can
read quite many case studies of the
application of BBC in a book I had the
pleasure of co-authoring with three
practitioners called integrating project
delivery in the book we build on many
successful examples from around the
world and we create the high-performing
building as the focus of what we need to
achieve and for that we need to define
it we call that measurable value you saw
examples of that definition at the
beginning of the slide tack and the key
role of course is to envision early on
in the project the performance you could
have with different kinds of designs for
that we need an integrated set of
information about the project that
supports visualization simulations
analysis optimizations so that we can
see what is really achievable and we
need to of course orchestrate the people
the organization and the processes so
that we create a building that is in the
type of
typically that building or that
structure and then I say building I
really mean it very broadly any anything
that we built in in the world typically
what we found that a high-performing
building has integrated systems we we
have technical systems that are
necessary for the building that really
support each other verbs in majestically
but those don't just happen by
themselves for that we really need to
bring the organization the process and
information together in integrative in
concept concentrated way so this allows
us to connect the three very common
acronyms IP de VDC BIM that we see
across the industry because we have
basically a strategy of integration to
create high performance buildings
supported by a tool like beam and if you
look over the top right the methods that
are used to execute this strategy we see
actually VDC we see the tools that are
used we see the collaboration we call it
I sessions we see production management
and vitiate exceed objectives so these
are the VDC capabilities and then we
also have alignment capabilities that
are also critical so I wanted to very
quickly position really see also in the
context of other common acronym so VDC
is not them it's not IP d VDC is the
method to execute the IP d strategy
integrated project delivery strategy and
bim is a critical part of receiver but
it's not the same as we see so very very
quickly I want to take you through a
personal journey so how did I arrive to
be passionate about VDC here's one of
the first projects I worked on to change
some rows on a bridge in Rhode Island we
had to redesign it so it was buildable
and two reflections one is why did the
designer and the Builder not work
together from the beginning for such a
complex project and why was it such a
struggle every day to find the right
information this really got me to
researching BIM
and then was sort of in a way validate I
felt validated with that direction when
I read about the Barcelona project from
Frank Gehry the golden fish restaurateur
there in 1992 because of the time
pressures of having the sculptures all
ready for the Olympics the structure was
built directly from the beam there was
an architect on site with a computer
with 3d model directly feeding the
information to the workers so that they
can install it rapidly so I thought okay
this is the kind of vision I also
believe in the construction tools
started to mature we were able to do our
first 3-d and 4-d model for the
renovation of the hospital right here in
San Mateo in 1993 and we saw the value
of them to bring diverse project team
together and focus it on important
issues over time people realized they
would be more effective when they work
together side by side from different
disciplines here you see the first big
room used by DPR construction and
subcontractors on a medical office
building here in Mountain View that was
in around 2003 2004 and on that project
they really brought many aspects of VDC
together because they also rethought the
process to leverage the collaboration of
the team and to leverage the the tools
for project success and the key thing
here is in the typical sequential flow
of work is this double-headed arrow
where the design team and the building
team together created a buildable
functional operable usable design
natural trial iteration around to value
the client for seeking and for that BIM
and this revised process and the
collaboration are absolutely critical so
the result of that project was that it
was build nine percent cheaper and six
percent six months faster than
comparable buildings there were many of
these types of projects going on around
us here so we started to see in the
early 2000s the value of bringing all of
the VDC elements together you see again
the VDC framework here illustrated with
these experiences over times
so let us now hopefully have a sense of
now by companies and professionals use
VDC and what we do see is let us further
illustrate that made a few case studies
from around the world so as we were
defining VDC at our recent recipients
number we saw that one of our
collaborators SP Sott paltry solutions
was working with the British Airport
Authority on the extension of the
Heathrow Express to Terminal five and
that really is to my knowledge the first
documented example of the application of
VDC we didn't call it VDC at the time
but I think it's still a good case study
to show where VDC came from and and and
to show how all the elements work
together on that project which was quite
a massive infrastructure project they
had a key challenge that they only had
three days of later on space available
for materials outside but they had a
rebar detailing and fabrication process
that had a variability of plus minus two
weeks over six weeks so it could take
four weeks it could take eight weeks so
you can see the disconnect here you have
four week variability but you only have
space for three days worth of materials
they said this is not gonna work this is
going to create a disaster we we may not
finish the project on time this was the
largest country project in Europe at the
time so this was a big deal so they said
okay we have to fix it so how did they
approach it they said well we have to
arrange in here to reap our production
process okay that's that's good that's a
that's a nice idea what does this
actually mean this means that we have to
be able to reduce the lead time from six
weeks to one week because that's where
the site and much more reliably signal
what rebar is needed we need to
basically cut out a variability and we
need to reduce the cycle time for
installation so it becomes more
predictable from two weeks to two days
so
here you see key parts of how we think
about VDC and how we bring VDC onto
projects you see focus on the actions
decisions we call them controllable
factors that you can take on your
projects and the objective with metric
quantify targets that you want to
achieve to make this action meaningful
and to connect it to what you want to do
because you can see how if you meet
these objectives if a better chance of
finishing the project contact which was
of course imperative and so another
strategy they had design the rebar for
pre-assembly the specific target was
that they wanted to have 75% of rebar
preassembled which 15 17 18 years ago
was really quite aggressive right that
they wanted to use pool planning for
about detailing verification so they
didn't have just-in-time delivery and
not exceeded three day lay down space
and that they wanted to collaboratively
detail the rebar in weekly digital build
sessions so that they could all agree
yes this is buildable rebar so to
illustrate that here the pour before and
after look at the process the process
for engineering absolutely critical part
by the attention to process project
production management then the design to
play assembly fully detailed rebar in
BIM now very common at the time much
less common first time I saw this on the
project used at wide scale and then the
pool process so that the site could
signal to the engineers okay we need
this rebar next week
now make it detail it and make it over
the course of the week and here may be
the centerpiece of the whole strategy
this weekly Digital build session where
basically everybody that has a say in
yes this is the right rebar it cost
estimate of the project manager site web
site Foreman fabricators and so on
partial engineer we were together in a
room and said yes this works we also
signing off you can see how much time
you can
out of a project schedule how much back
and forth in Karratha if you can bring
the people together with good tools in
in the right process so put that back
into the BDC framework we saw here how
the combination of defining the
challenge the objective and then in
measurable ways led to the targeted
re-engineering of the process which was
only then the execution was only
possible by having these weekly digital
build sessions they were supported by a
very detailed BIM and if you take one of
those pieces out you don't have a
successful project and that's what we
have for you be seen time and again and
that's really something that is critical
when you use VDC is to not stop at just
using PMO not stop at just using lean
may there may be a little bit of a more
not just stopping at collaboration to
really bring all of these work methods
together and to be very deliberate
deliberate about what objectives you're
trying to achieve so I'll turn it over
to Danielle to share a couple of case
studies from her experience a little bit
of an echo maybe somebody else known you
so many shared three examples for you
today
I chose these examples because BBC was
used to address a very specific
challenge or project goal and I'm hoping
that by going through these three
examples pretty quickly you'll be able
to imagine how EDC can be used on your
project so I'd like to start with the
projects where a large co-working office
developer approached us with a specific
goal of how they could build projects
faster it was sort of interesting how
this project came about we had Rana VDC
workflow with one of our general
contractors finds on one of their
co-working projects this developer has
very high liquidated damages if the
project is late but they also have a
bonus if the project
and so through that VDC workflow with
the general contractor we were able to
help them achieve that bonus so the
owner came to us and said hey if this
project could have been built that fast
that should have been the project
schedule from the beginning how can you
help us build all of our projects faster
so we said we think we can do that
through by utilizing 4d BIM in a well
run BBC framework and I think one
important things to note about this
developer is that they only start leases
on the 1st of the month so it's two days
away really turns into a one-month delay
which means that there's both
construction cost implications and then
also a loss of revenue so what we did
was we created a 4d BIM by utilizing the
designs in and then taking the original
general contractors construction
schedule we use pool planning
methodologies to get information from
the trade contractors to understand what
what are their productivities what is
their task sequence saying what
durations do we need to assume and then
we ran through this with a very specific
goal of cutting the schedule by 20% what
was sort of interesting here is we were
able to achieve that but we did not
change any durations and we didn't
change any productivity rates right it
would be very easy to say hey the wall
framing is on the critical path it's 10
days let's do it in five days and we'll
say you know 5 days from your
construction schedule we kept all the
products of these durations was a given
we only thought about resequencing work
so we were able to say things like hey
there's a lot of work happening in zone
hey nothing's happening in zones II
don't see how do we get a crew out there
or we have lighting installed following
you have to work install with this much
of a lag because we have the schedule in
this very visual collaborative format we
can see that there's space to shorten
that lag so can we do that this is how I
tried to map those projects use
the BBC framework so you can see really
how it all came together so as I said
there was this project objective of
maximizing these revenues should we get
one extra month of revenue and reducing
scheduled duration by 20% but what's
really important to note here is how
that really rolls up into client
objectives where you can then apply that
schedule saving methodology from the
projects across the global portfolio and
I think this is an important point
because it shows that we're able to
close the feedback loop right what we've
learned here with one BBC workflow on
one project we can scale across multiple
projects and really take advantage of
that money the 4d BIM was obviously that
essential tool that was used for both
visualization and schedule optimisation
but it was really by putting it together
with I sessions so that we could have
real-time decision-making for how do we
sequence work and putting it together
with that for planning methodology so as
martin says it's really more than the
BIM it's how it comes together with both
the people on the process side the next
example I'd like to share is for
wastewater treatment plants large-scale
projects where the challenge here is
specifically to eliminate rework during
construction it's been a problem on past
projects you can see just by the density
and complexity in the scale of the
building this is a challenge with the
challenge they face before and it's a
challenge that resulted in both cost
schedule overrun or cost overruns and
schedule delays so we built the BDC
workflow that specifically targeted two
goals first eliminate clashes between
systems virtually before they happened
in the field and second enabled
prefabrication of certain systems so
that work on-site was breached right and
if work on-site should be reduced that
rework could be eliminated so when
thinking through the BIM execution plan
the level of development of the fan was
aligned for these two bulls and so the
majority of the of the model was
three-sixty but for certain strategic
items that were going to be
prefabricated the LED was 400 and you
know architectural instructional
elements depending on me and the
importance and the interface with those
strategic MEP F system with either a
linear 300 or 350 the entire team
realized the importance of clash
detection and issue management and
achieving that rework reduction goal so
very detailed approach approach was used
here for every issue six attributes were
stressed right and so please note that
not all issues were geometric clashes
necessarily issues could be identified
related to construct ability model
fidelity order of operations right that
construction sequencing for example and
then these six attributes were analyzed
by our team as well as the general
contractor was estimating team to
determine the impact that they had on
the project right mainly the avoidance
of man-hours labor paths or material
cost the status the open date the close
date that I note here are actually
incredibly interesting because it helps
us from a process perspective and
enabled us to understand the real-time
status of issues this slide shows how
that data was visualized I realize is
probably quite hard to see so I'll walk
through it quickly but here in table one
issues tightness you see that the
majority of clashes are in a light blue
color which means their trade
coordination issues as an accountant or
example very liberal than yellow which
uncovers through designer shoes or air
so we can see that these issues really
can be solved through good construction
phase VDC workflows table two helps us
prioritize the issues you can see that
about a quarter of the issues are high
priority of critical that's where we
should focus our time to have the
biggest impact on a project Table three
shows which trades are conflicting with
each other the largest amount of clashes
are between two trades process piping
and electrical so we could see there
that we would benefit from ice session
breakouts between those two trades
bringing the right people together at
that right time to solve those problems
at the end of the day the owner wanted
to see right was all of this work
working so we had to quantify the effort
so we tried to quantify cost or time
reduction so our team Nords with the
general contractors estimators to take
the class reports and calculate
man-hours saved in cos fate by resolving
the issues early through VDC rather than
encountering those issues in the field
so really justifying this BDC work for
for future projects here we're going to
adapt what I just went through to the
VDC framework what I'd like you to focus
on here in this particular example is
that 100% of the ice thin and ppm
activities were aligned to that very
specific challenge I mentioned at the
beginning reducing rework in the field
right and that's the clients objectives
to reduce rework which led to projects
objectives of clash detection and
prefabrication so close I'd like to talk
about how we DC has been expended
through the project lifecycle I think
it's very easy to focus VDC just on the
design and construction phase but it is
important to understand that this can
have a life through facilities
management and operation so here's the
project we stayed at a university with a
with a specific focus on building
operations the challenge presented by
the owner was that if facilities
management same workflow could help
reduce the project lifecycle cost and
streamline facilities management and
operations processes
here's a snapshot to give you a better
idea of what was happening on the
project so we had the project fin that
was created throughout the design and
construction process which we then links
to customized asset data as well as
Oh Ellen document operating and
maintenance document we worked with the
owner to determine what size attributes
are most important the facilities
managing operations processes that
became the asset ID or assets had the
equipment types manufacturer and model
number as well as the room location that
locational data is quite important men
each piece of information
H piece of equipment with some links to
the O&M anyone this became a great tool
for them both from a visual perspective
and from a data perspective you think
through the software work for you see
that we had a software that became
really that central environment where
the building could be visualized and
where the data from those various
sources was placed on the right side of
the slider you see just that spreadsheet
of data and I think when you juxtapose
this spreadsheet of data to what I
showed before you really start to see
the value of putting everything in that
central location and having a data and
visual ring it became an important tool
to make this building information more
accessible for any stakeholder involved
in operations facilities management or
engaged in future construction or
renovation effort my site is not
advancing can somebody help me advance
to the next famous
and it looks like it doesn't like the
video funny all right perfect there we
go so I'd like to leave you with with
this visual of how we've extended this
idea on other projects so here you see a
virtual walkthrough of a mechanical room
where you know now stakeholders from all
around the world can get a glimpse into
their projects and be able to pull up
and sports an information about their
project what we've noticed is that in
light of the remote working situation
forced by the kovat 19 pandemic there's
even more value out of these
applications and you can imagine how
stakeholders from anywhere in the world
right can now take a glimpse inside that
so I'd like to end with just recapping
that PVC frame works really quickly if
someone can help me get this to any if
too many cooks
I think we can we can transition to the
next example
martsin if you'd like that no I mean the
recap slightest error I actually can't
see it so I think if we look at the
recap slide here again what I'd like to
note is how the VTC framework and the
activities does are through them through
ice and through ppm are all in done with
done in line with those projects and
climb effective and we really
highlighting that from a project level
there's already value but if you start
to extend this value through that
enterprise and being able to take these
learnings across multiple projects
you're really able to make the most of
it so with that I'll turn it back to you
I'm sorry for the technical hiccups
thanks Danielle
for showing the application of EBC
really across many phases of of projects
and different types of projects I want
to just conclude with very very rapidly
with a couple more case examples to show
you the global reach of EDC because
you've seen project teams really around
the world taking advantage of EDC here
John's a Korean sleekness from cruiser
Smith let the deployment of VDC for the
delivery of a University building in
Vestal Norway and that the client had
simply the request we want the best
teaching building in western Norway
nothing more than that
that included dramatically reduced co2
emissions at 3m excellent grading net
zero energy building C or mistakes his
hand over of course on time budget all
of those things that are quite typical
in terms of client and project
objectives they here you see the
workroom they have very happy.i session
the collaboration sessions where they
really focused on making sure everything
was as prefabricated as possible that
the construction was really coordinated
with the design sequence all the
technical systems were coordinated
and that each meeting had very clear
agendas objective systems and so that
the team was effective and successful in
terms of the application of BIM they
used it for looking again at
prefabrication options the areas of
management on-site the coordination of
technical systems 40 models to share
progress connected with production
quantities to have a reality check they
brought the temporary structures in and
make sure that they didn't collide and
they positioned tested all the crane
locations in BIM then and in terms of
production management they really
connected they brought basically the
daily planning weekly planning into a
digital environment they develop
software to do so they connected that
with them so that they could really
execute day to day the ambitious targets
they have and so so you can see again
the combination of all the elements if
you see they tracked how they're doing
regularly here you see how they tracked
their collaboration sessions you can see
that they had a bit and then they fixed
it and then eventually they had a big
dip and they said oh oops there's no
longer working we thought they had it
but the Danish al we don't and then they
were able to have I sessions at a high
level this was founded very very simple
questions like what's this session good
did you have meaningful input questions
like that which we see quite commonly
done to create rapid feedback loop for
the team how things are going so they
were able to reduce the duration by
three months they and shorten a few
other parts of the project as well
contributed to three months and they
were able to take a million of
contingency funding out of the project
which of course the CFO was very happy
with and you see if he are represented
all of these points in the BDC framework
again you see once again if you take one
of those elements out it's just
quite so successful and finally very
rapidly deserves like a whole
presentation on its own Raul is a theory
from gossipy let the deployment of VDC
to deliver very successfully the main
facilities for the Pan Am Games in Lima
design and build 97 thousand square
meters of Motorsports facility in 18
months I think quite an achievement this
was of course highly scalable critical
high quality had to be achieved and as
you if you followed the games last year
it was very very successful thanks in
part of this performance from this team
they again brought the right people
together in these AI sessions integrated
engineering sessions where they managed
to solve 15 critical issues and average
every two hour sessions and a few
sessions each week for long period you
can see five sessions per week and
they're typically included 10 team
members so that right everybody was on
the same page and solved the problems
together in terms of BIM they solved
4,000 issues before or she went into
construction so that construction could
run much more smoothly and you see again
the involvement of the different
participants to give your data in their
sense of the scale of it and in terms of
managing the process one of the key
successes here was that they in the
earlier sessions created how the team
was going to work together so that
everybody was again on the same page
with the procedures they're going to
follow and establish how they're going
to use the comdata environment again
with a multidisciplinary team of tempest
a--'s 10k participants so here you see a
way of one example of how they measure
the progress of BIM and how it
contributed to resolving clashes and and
create a smooth construction so they
found that it was important to get the
client involved to define the common
objectives to really focus in the first
I sessions on
how to work together on the project that
also they learned that those sessions
take a lot of effort to plan if you want
to have them run well use the cloud and
to not only just map the process but
really use it in a continuous
improvement cycle with it plan do study
act approach so we hope that with these
examples you've seen the the breadth of
use of EDC around the world and also in
terms of types of projects and project
phases so two to recap BDC is really
about the power of M meaning you know
the definition of objectives KPI is if
you like that word to be supported by
collaboration integrated confrontation
earring with Building Information
modeling and attention to process
managing the production of the project
so we DC aligns the definition of
measurable client and project objectives
with the planning design engineering
management methods the people process
technology to achieve these objectives
so thank you for tuning in for listening
to this introduction of EDC and we hope
we were able to the mystify VDC but also
give you some inspiration in terms of
how you can bring it to your projects
thank you so much Martin and Danielle
that was that was wonderful
and I think that's a perfect segue so
you develop and you work with
professionals to develop and to be sort
of a educational experience to get
people up to speed on BBC and you've
also gone through a lot of really
wonderful examples of successful
implementations when you're teaching
this or when you're talking with people
who are trying to implement vbc what do
you see what are you and Danielle see is
the major impetus to successfully
implementing DBC you talked a lot about
engaging with the owners and there's a
lot of extra time and sort of giving
them to meet regularly to develop the
BBC plans so maybe that's one obstacle
but in general when you've seen an
unsuccessful implementation what's gone
wrong I'm cursin deceive Antonius as I
would say that the biggest challenge
we've seen around the world is
definition of mesh
world project and client objectives to
really create a target for the project
that for some reason has been quite
challenging and of course we will work
through in the in the in the program how
to do so and then how do you how to use
them the other I would say is that multi
l - is that the VDC elements are used in
isolation is too much this focus on BIM
but not enough attentional process of
collaboration always focus on working
together but not quite enough use or the
other elements and so on so the the
power of end is not realized and the
third one is that people are working in
isolation so they are on their project
they're trying to do great things you
know many things cutting away and what
we've seen is by creating a community of
practitioners that want to implement VDC
on their projects the learning gets
accelerated very rapidly that the things
that work gets shared that things that
don't work at shared in a way that's
very meaningful to the situation you
face at the moment and that community
has proven to be very very helpful in
guiding you out of your frustration and
isolation that we typically often see on
projects then you try to innovate I
don't know if these yeah I can add a
little bit and I think it's
complementary to what you brought up so
I don't think there's one implementation
challenge that we always see right
there's it's usually a combination of a
few things kind of coming together I do
find that the project team and the owner
can set the strong vision that really
lays the groundwork for success when
that vision is not strong and when
people start we start to lose sight of
the challenge we're trying to solve for
or the goals that we have on that
project it starts to break down very
quickly and all of a sudden you have
people that are that are doing a lot of
work they don't understand what they're
working for anymore so I think that that
vision is key and more often than that I
find this very
breakdowns on the people side less on
the tool side right we know that with
the right software the right hardware
and some training we can create that's
the thing right and put some of those
tools together but it's usually more
about people or process side and so I
think that's why I like understanding
that full VDC framework is so important
because you really understand how all
those different components comes
together because it's even one of those
starts to break down you end up with
implementation challenges I think the
the value of learning from people on
projects across the globe is that
somebody is probably going through that
same challenge for has gone through that
challenge before so you don't have to
just learn from your own mistakes you
can learn from the mistakes of those
that came before you and benefit from
that it's fantastic could you maybe
elaborate a little bit on sort of
getting people on board we've gotten
quite a few questions about how do you
engage with owner
I mean I'm convinced that BBC is the way
to go with how do you engage with the
owners and convincing them to adopt PDC
especially if there's an entire cost in
terms of time or resources I think that
people typically face when talking to
owners is that they very very quickly
get into the weave of it into the book
what are we going to do
and I think when talking to owners and
one's starting to think about how do you
line DDC with those overall organization
objectives and the big picture on the
project like you need to start wider
than that you need to start with hey
what's the vision what's the values and
maybe never actually talk about how the
models are created or what sort of like
ppm work for they're gonna be use at the
beginning right they need to understand
the overall value composition and then I
think when it comes to cost because I
saw that that was specifically mentioned
in one other question there's a big
difference between upfront cost and
total project
cause and so yes you might spend more
hops right now and the planning phase
but guaranteed that saves me money in
the examples I showed right it saves you
money in general conditions they see
money in rework cause and so I think
there needs to be a reframing of what
that cost means and that all comes down
to metrics so if we can't measure it we
can't we don't know if it's working or
not and we don't know how to make
changes so the metrics part of the VDC
frameworks I think is essential here so
picking up on that but one way in which
I've seen a project team successfully
not everybody else to go along and see
the value VDC is by establishing a share
metric that matter to both for example
on one project a large infrastructure
project on the East Coast the project
manager for the consultant together with
the client they sat down and they said
you know what what has messed up your
project in the past and so the shared
sort of over coffee
challenges that they had faced and they
realized that one common challenge they
had was answers to questions from the
engineering team by the client and so
then they they agreed how long
depression should be now they had a
metric they could track and they could
then use to adjust the workflows adjust
the user tools such as the use of timing
of bringing people in etc and so that
that created sort of the initial
yardstick that matter to both that allow
them to and innovate in the context of
that project project teams have created
this alignment between the project team
and the owner by really understanding
what the client really wants from the
facility and sometimes for some reason
or not that open to that but all those
actually all once you start asking
questions and and that has become then
that allowed them to focus not only on
the cost but also on the value of the
facility and that became very important
in terms of
the focus at the bend the people
involved in decision-making etc and this
again started to get the VDC framework
going on the project so it's it's really
through early conversations either-or
sort of creating a bigger picture or
vision for the project as aniele also
alluded to all by probably both and
would be ideal and creating a specific
metric that you can track frequently
that allows you to then show bring me
DCM so those are a couple successful
approaches I've seen we've also gotten a
few questions and sort of the spread and
future of VDC and so the first one is do
you other is it spreading to do types
and you've seen implementations of heavy
civil construction such as dams or
tunnels similar you got a question
whether you've seen VDC being brought
into manufacturing industries either it
might be useful in developing cars or
complex manufacturing like airplanes so
they've definitely seen it across small
big projects across the infrastructure
or industrial institutional complex
buildings housing multi-family
residential so we've seen it applied in
many settings because right if you think
about it why would a project be worse if
you defined its goals if you use
collaboration if you use the good
process if you use in your good tools so
so that it really we have seen can help
you in all types of projects the
interesting question about the
application to other sectors actually I
usually turn it around because you've
seen many you have probably seen the
curve of you know declining or stagnant
construction productivity and increase
in productivity in manufacturing in
other industries sometimes we show that
we didn't show it today because we
figured that has been shown many times
produced by my colleague
and yes back here at safety Paul titled
initially and so then I was reflecting
on why do we see this difference and
also I was reflecting because people ask
me Moulton why are you so convinced that
VD sees the right way to do it so
basically right manufacturing has
increased a value-add compared to
construction by a factor of two and a
half over the last 50 years at least in
the u.s. that's in a way bad in a way a
great opportunity for us but if you
reflect what is different 50 years ago
in manufacturing and construction and
now 50 years ago in manufacturing you
didn't see well define metrics
objectives you didn't have lean
management processes never attention to
process you didn't have digital tools
you know you didn't have design for
manufacturing we didn't have integration
of the organization today it would be
totally unthinkable that a pro bleeding
manufacturing company does so without
having a full digital model of what it's
building without bringing design and
manufacturing together without thinking
about the use of and without
establishing clear objectives you're not
measuring adjusting the workflow
understanding it Mellow just a
continuously so you see exactly the VDC
elements represented in and in the
difference in added value over power
that has been achieved over the last 50
years manufacturing and that I think we
can get to influenced by deploying BTC
um Thank You Martin and y'all for you
for your time that was wonderful and so
a nice way to sort of end VD see him
anyway and to implement some of
efficiency gains that we see sectors and
to speed it up and deeper more efficient
smarter as we said in the title thank
you both for joining us thank you
everyone who join us today a recording
of the webinar will be made available in
about a week and we appreciate you / -
I'm sorry all the questions but I'll be
sending them to Danielle Martin so they
can take whatever one was that thank you
again
you